I think somebody mentions that this
Workforce plan was first raised by
Jeremy Hunt over five years ago we've
been hearing from the the current
Administration here that the workforce
plan would be issued since January but
it's here it was published about 15
minutes ago 151 Pages adding more detail
to what we know already Samantha about
those tens of thousands of extra
training places for doctors nurses and
other Healthcare professionals we've
been pouring over some of the the key
numbers here and I'll go through some of
them and essentially what this plan does
it is to grow the workforce to retrain
the workforce where it needs to with the
addition of extra technology and
essentially to retain that Workforce
the government wants to work towards a
plan over the next five 10 and 15 years
where it is less dependent on overseas
trained health professionals and they
have given us in their modeling and data
the sort of projections over the next
few years but essentially what this
means is that we won't see the benefits
of this long-term Workforce plan in the
short term and it won't do anything to
address things like social care or NHS
Estates but certainly there has been
almost a universal welcome for this
Workforce plan from everyone the the
experts in health and Tech and the think
tanks as well sixty thousand more
doctors 170 000 more nurses 71 000 more
Allied health professionals aim to
retain
130 extra staff so that would be an
extra 431
000 staff by 2031 that's an increase of
34 almost a quarter of NHS staff will be
trained via apprenticeship by 2031-32
and medical degree apprenticeships two
thousand to be trained by
2031-32 that is the idea is to train
more NHS staff domestically so in 15
years time we can expect around nine to
ten percent of our Workforce to be
recruited from overseas compared to
nearly a quarter right now they'll also
be encouraging retired doctors to come
back to the NHS and they've announced
support staff for the NHS as well and
this is why they're doing this because
we have an aging and complex aging
population with complex Health needs the
workforce has shrunk in real terms when
you consider the amount of patients they
have to see over the next 15 years the
population of England is projected to
increase by 4.2 percent but the number
of people ages over 85 will grow by 55
and these people will have complex
Health needs which need care and at the
moment the NHS is we as we all know
struggling to cope the idea is to grow
the workforce over the next 5 10 15
years so it can meet the demands of a
growing and aging population